ونحييكم متابعينا من جديد في الملف السوري
جاءت تصريحاته بالتزامن مع التقارب التركي
الذي من المحتمل ان ينتهي بلقاء الرئيسيين
بشار الاسد واردوغان هنا اكد لينكن انا
واشنطن طلبات جميع الاطراف في سوريا بخفض
التصعيد خصوصا تركيا حيث اشار وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي اشار الى ان اي عمليه
عسكريه في سوريا
مضيفا ان تركيا يمكنها حل مشاكلها في شمال
سوريا بدون اللجوء الى الحل العسكريه
وفيما يخص مخاوف تركيا في شمال سوريا فقد
اكد بلانكين على انها مشروعه كما جدد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه رفضه واشنطن للتطبيعه
مع نظام بشار الاسد مؤكدا ان واشنطن تريد
ان تكون العمليه السياسيه في سوريا
مواثيقه
مع قرارات مجلس الامن
فيما يخص شمالي سوريا حاولنا تهدئه الجميع
ولا نريد تدخل عسكريا شمالي سوريا وهو ما
قد يؤخر الجهود لرضع تنظيم داعش ولن يكون
في مصلحه احد تركيا لديها مصالح امنيه
مشروعه واعتقد انه يمكن تحقيقها دون تداخل
عسكري فيما يخص النظام الاسد نحن لا ندعم
التطبيعه معه الامم المتحده اقترحت عمليه
لتنفيذ قراراتها ونحن ندعم ذلك الا ان
النظام الاسد يرفضها
[موسيقى]
هناك هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا هنا معنا
من اسطنبول الدكتور
اهلا بك يا دكتور بكير واسمح لي ان ابدا
معك دكتور بكير وزير الخارجيه الامريكيهن
على قناه العربيه وفي لقائنا في قناه
العربيه بتصريحات قال فيها بان الولايات
المتحده تعارف في الواقع العمليه البريه
التي تحضر لها او تفكر فيها تركيا هل
فاجئكم هذا الموضوع خاصه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مساء الخير تحياتي لكم
يعني
في العربيه الدارجه في سوريا يقولون صح
النوم
وزير الخارجيه الان الذي يقول باننا ضد
لماذا لان المسرحيه التي التي مازالت
يمثلون عليها على وشك النهايه يعني انتهت
هذه الحلقه الاخيره من قبل النهايه الحلقه
الاخيره الولايات المتحده لا تستطيع ان
تستمر بهذا الشكل بهذا الشكل على اساس
خداع شعوب المنطقه همم
بين بعضهم البعض لان الولايات المتحده هي
التي تريد
تطبيع مع النظام وليست تركيا او الدول
الاخرى هي التي تطبع مع النظام والدليل
على ذلك كيف دخلت روسيا على سوريا اليسا
بدعوه رسميه من
جون كيري الذي كان وزيرا للخليه
في التطبيع مع النظام السوري وتقول ما
يخالف ذلك لماذا
نحن نحن با ترفضه الولايات عفوا ما تطلبه
الايات المتحده سوف نفعل العكس فاذا قالت
على تركيا ان لا تتدخل في الشمال السوري
او في سوريا سوف نتدخل بالرغم من هذا
الطلب وقريبا سوف تجدونها عندما تقول
الولايات المتحده نحن نرفض التطبيع مع
النظام السوري تركيا سوف تطبع بالرغب من
طلب الولايات المتحده لان هذا الطلب غير
منطقي وكاذب وخادع خادع للشعوب السعوديه
ما تقول نحن ضد التطبيع بمعنى اخر هي تريد
مصلحتها على حساب شعب التركي على حساب
الشعب السوري على حساب مصالح الدول
المنطقه كلها لذلك نحن نقول بالرغم منها
عندما تقول نحن لا نريد تدخل تركي هي كيف
تدخل من الاف المترات كيلوميترات وتدعم
هذه العصابه
صحيح
هذه قراءتك همم استاذه شروان كيف قرات
تصريحات وزير الخارجيه الامريكا انطونيو
في ما يخص هذه العمليه البريه التركيه
المنتظره الدكتور بكير يقول حتى مع هذا
الرفض نحن مصممون على هذه الخطوه
همم تركي لن تستطيع ذلك لان لها
التزاماتها يبدو ان الرئيس
كل الاطراف في هذه الحلف لهم التزاماتهم
ولا تستطيع يبدو ان الرئيس التركي لن يصلي
في الجامع الاموي
مع بشر الاسد ولا باسقاطه
الاعوام الفائته اثبت همم اثبتت انقره ان
السياساتها فاشله همم
اليوم تتوسل الى دمشق لكي همم
انت تقول بانه لتركيا ولن
ده ما خطوه دون اا اا خط او دون اا ضوء
اخضر من واشنطن هذا مستحيل تستعد حاضر
استبعد ذلك لان هناك همم دلائل تشير الى
ذلك اولا كما قلنا ان همم
[موسيقى]
التزاماتها مع لحلف الناتو ولا تستطيع ذلك
اللاعب بين الاقضاء الدوليه بين روسيا
وهمم الولايات المتحده لماذا لان تركيا
همم اكدت فشل همم التزاماتها بذلك فمثلا
الرئيس التركي اردوغان في 2019 في مجلس
الامم المتحده في نيويورك نيويورك همم رفع
الخارطه وقال بانني ساحتل هذه المناطق او
ساخرج هذه المناطق الشمال السوري لكي تكون
مناطق مستقره وامنه ولكن همم بعد همم
احتلال تركه
همم راينا ذلك في همم 2018 احتلت
وفي 2019 احتلت همم سيري كانيه وبعد هذا
الاحتلال تم همم استهداف امراء
وقاده داعش في تركيا المنطقه وتحولت الى
بؤره وملجا من لداعش وايضا همم نقطه اخرى
همم قبل عده ايام كانت هناك ذكرى لهجوم
على سجن غويران في الحسكه 2022
وهمم هناك مركز استقصائي تحقيق بريطاني
نشات تقريبا اكد على ان الاسلحه المستخدمه
في الهجوم على سجن غويران كانت اسلحه تعود
للجيش الوطني التابع لتركيا اذا تلك
المناطق تحولت الى همم همم الى اماكن وبؤر
ل همم انعاش داعش وتجديد داعش مجددا لذلك
الولايات المتحده لن تمسح المجال مجددا
امام داعش لكي داعش وحضرتك تحدثت عن داعش
هو تحدث ذلك عن داعش وقال وهنا سؤال حذرتك
الدكتور بكير همم لان بلنك قال بان همم
عمليه عمليه تركيا ستصعب كذلك الماموريه
على التحالف فما يخص بؤر داهيه عشان
موجوده شمال سوريا فهذا لن يمكن الاتراك
اكثر واكثر من التوخل
سيدتي العزيزه اذا اخذنا بيع الاعتبار
تصريحات الاخيره على في قناتكم قبل ايام
عديده
تصريحات ااا
الذي يدعي بانه والجنرال قائد قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه قال بانهم يحذر من تدخل تركي
وسوف
لذلك تركيا العمليه العسكريه قادمه
واضح جدا بان تركيا قادمه ولم تسال او
موافقه لروسيا ولا الولايات المتحده ولا
اي دوله لان الامن القومي لتركيا لا تمر
عبر الولايات المتحده عبر روسيا تمر عبر
القرار التركي عبره قرار الشعب التركي
وسوف تجدون قريبا هل هذه تحقق املا همم
نتكلم كل مره
ولكن صحيح
لانه بقى لي القليل من الوقت الحديث على
دمشق كذلك لان بلنكن تحدث عن ان واشنطن
تعارض التطبيع مع دمشق رايك فيها كذا
تصريح سيد شروان همم
الولايات المتحده لا تريد
اطراف
التطبيع مع دمشق هو خاصه
يعني تركيا ما زالت يعني بلدان اطلسيان
وغربيا بصفتها القائمه التي يريد رئيسها
الحالي تغير هذه الصفه والتقرب من ربما
همم من روسيا بعد همم انقلاب 2016
الحديثه هنا همم الولايات المتحده لا تريد
همم ان تعطي نصرا سياسيا مجانيا لروسيا
لماذا لماذا
الولايات المتحده همم الان همم تحارب
روسيا في جميع انحاء العالم وتفردوا عليه
العقوبات
وتمنع من اي دوله اتعامل مع روسيا فلن همم
تمسح المجال امام حليفتها تركيا ضمن حلف
الناتو لكي تتعامل مع روسيا روسيا التي
تروج روس تروج لمشروع المصالحه على انهم
على انهم مشروعا لحل الازمه السوريه التي
عجزت عنه الدول التي سنوات القادمه
لذلك لن تسمح همم
الخطوه لن تسمح لتركيا بطبيع مع النظام
السوري دكتور بكير باختصار شديد لو سمحت
يعني صرنا نتحدث عن نقطتين تمانع همم
واشنطن تنفيذهما النقطه الاولى هي العمليه
البريه وتحدثنا فيها نقطه ثانيه وعشان
ثانيه بانها تمنع تطبيعها مع نظام الاسد
ولكنها لا ترى كذلك بعين همم يعني همم
قابله لهذا التطبيع التركي السوري
سيدتي العزيزه قبل يومين هناك اجتماع
بحمايه امريكيه بامتياز
للمعارضين المعارضه يعني الذين يعرضون
المعارضه الموجوده الان مع حزب الاتحاد
الديمقراطي حزب العمال الكردستاني في جنيف
وقبل يومين لذلك
الولايات المتحده تريد ان تلعب على حبلين
لذلك انا قلت واكرر بان اذا طلبت الولايات
المتحده
خرجت اصبح
اساسيه
لان هؤلاء مرتزقه يجب ان ينته ليس لهم حل
سوى القضاء عليهم هؤلاء قتله قتلت شعوب
القرد في شمال سوريا في جميع مناطق العالم
هؤلاء القتل لا بد ان ينته ولو هذه
المعارضه همم لان لا لا المرتزقه لا حياه
بعد الان لان الولايات المعارضه انها خريه
سيطره عليها تركيا
في تمثيل الثوره السوريه
كما تدعيه اصبحت اجنده وتابعه لتركيا
الى تنظيم داعش لماذا قامت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه همم
وحدات حمايه الشعب بالاسلحه مباشره
عن البديل شكرا جزيلا لكما واسمحوا لي ان
نقف عند هذا الحد الاستقمال بقيه النقاط
الاكيد بانه سيكون النقاش بقيه في خصوص
هذه النقطه او شكرا يوسف مدير وكاله نورس
بريس وشكرا كذلك الحظر تكمل اسطنبول دكتور
بكيره تاجان مدير ما حد اسطنبول للفكر
شكرا لكم